bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur
vous m'excuse pour
me voyez des bambous ici c'est pas en
tant que un cadre sélectuel je suis là
et quand Macron parle le français moi
j'entends pas mais quand moi je parle
Français Macron en temps
et
tu parles en tant que un cadre je suis
là en tant que président fondateur
orphelinat aide aux enfants déshérités
de Guinée qui est depuis 3 décembre 2015
je suis dans Ça c'est un cadre des
enfants c'est un bon à l'école certains
font au métier soit la tapisserie et la
menuiserie et la soudure exetera des
métiers donc depuis 2015 et d'abord je
remercie TEDx Bambeto qui a pu organiser
à donner des noms de chez moi Bambeto je
suis fier de ça et merci à tous personne
qui a laissé ton temps pour bénir nous
suivre et aux enfants déshérités depuis
et deux enfants de victimes 3 décembre
2015 aujourd'hui dieu merci et comme
l'année passée et on a eu trois enfants
alors faire là qui sont libres trois
enfants qui sont examens on a une enfant
qui a eu premier à 8e année pour aller à
NBA et on a des enfants aujourd'hui que
j'ai commencé depuis 3 décembre 2015 des
enfants que j'ai pris au centre émetteur
qui peut au garde routière Bambeto
aujourd'hui c'est ses enfants là ils
n'étaient pas
d'espoir mais grâce à l'ONG a donné ses
enfants la d'espoir quoi aujourd'hui ces
enfants fabriquent de canapés de
fabrique des antivols exetera
aujourd'hui des enfants je te dis que
moi on a commencé l'autre finale a
commencé de récolter ce qu'ils ont
planté et ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui et aux enfants de vérités
n'est pas pour seulement dans
l'orphelinat ou bien à Bambeto ici
seulement ou bien à ratona seulement non
une vision des visions quoi et deux
enfants de vérité doit s'installer à
tous ces communes de Conakry pour
récupérer des enfants à la rue on a
tellement des enfants à la rue et deux
enfants de vision
pourquoi pas des quatre régions
naturelles à un centre même pas
aux régions de la Guinée donc et aux
enfants de vérités aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup de encore de difficultés
puisque pour encadrer des enfants même
si c'est des enfants qui avec toi c'est
tout un problème moi je suis père de
cinq enfants destinés en 70 je mets 52
ans mais j'aimerais qu'il part jusqu'à
ma mort soit le temps
c'est pas l'état je peux dire que depuis
j'ai commencé c'est pas l'état qui
m'accompagne peut-être je peux dire que
si vous entendez aujourd'hui et aux
enfants de vérités vu on entend en train
d'encadrer les enfants je peux dire
grâce à Bakary Diaby puisque c'est lui
qui peut nous local c'est appartient pas
à moi on a un village de 4500 par mois
c'est pas moi qui paye avec mes dépenses
avec les enfants vont tomber malade mais
je peux dire et Dieu merci
et l'année passée
je vis une visite et j'ai vu des
visiteurs excellence l'ambassade des
États-Unis chez moi avec Miss Saramba
quand il est venu beaucoup penser que
l'ambassadeur a envoyé des enveloppes de
dollars pour moi
[Applaudissements]
quand il mange est-ce que ces gens
parlentis n'ont pas vu avoir de manger
en cas en cas on souhaite pas en cas de
guerre en cas de rébellion ce que ces
hommes parlent là qui vont être microbes
puisque il va pas avoir mangé si vous
voyez on dit que nous sommes des
violents je vais vous dire que on n'est
pas de violence
c'est l'état avant qui a oublié de nous
mais quand même on demande de retour de
l'État chez nous si il y a des on a des
jeunes compétences on a des mouvements
comme exemples PSG DDD petit Dédé c'est
une jeune c'est de jeunes aujourd'hui
qui sont mobilisés aujourd'hui on est
nationale même je suis membre fondateur
des collectifs agissons autrement je
suis membre fondateur donc tout ça là
c'est pour la non-violence comme des
idées
a formé des gens ici on a commencé à
Conakry jusqu'à l'intérieur du pays pour
former des enfants pour mieux former des
gens avec les forces les gendarmes et
les polices en tout cas pour qu'on donne
la main pour que sa violence là c'est
chez nous ici mais il y a certains
enfants qui sont ici il connaît même pas
pourquoi ils sortent ces manifester
monsieur ses enfants sont pas occupés de
s'en prendre son bandonnés comme ça ce
que je veux dire c'est pas puisque je
suis là en qualité des Bambois des
bambous pour dire que c'est il y a voilà
il est qualifié non c'est pas un peu de
diplômes qui compte c'est de travail au
terrain qui compte moi je suis au
terrain
donc
ce que je veux dire aussi
j'ai eu la chance je remercie d'abord
les personnes qui a organisé de me
donner une micro de bambous ici des
cadres qui sont certains sont des
diplômes des bambou pour que mes enfants
de faire peut-être je pense bien ça ça
va tomber dans une journée de quelqu'un
ici pour venir nous aider on
l'orphelinat
et puisque je connais comment ça passe
là-bas des fois même pour avoir des
nourriture c'est tout un problème je
vous dis si c'est pas Bakary Diaby allez
là ça va trouver que j'ai déjà abandonné
puisque moi je peux pas c'est une
travail de l'État que j'ai en train de
mener au laxe ici donc partir l'enfant
j'ai beaucoup bâti au barbecue ici tout
mouvement peut-être tous les
journalistes qui sont là ou bien qui
n'ont pas là peut-être il y a pas un
journal qui peut pas dire que on va
essayer à ne pas me défendre à bambetou
combien de cas j'ai eu des caméras que
j'allais retirer avec des des voilà etc
donc on a on a une objective donc
Bambeto je vais vous dire une chose
aujourd'hui n'est pas de violent il y a
des gens qui vont quitter quelque part
pour venir plus allons à bambique on va
chercher dépenses ça il y en a donc on a
des jeunes cadre exemple je vais vous
donner une exemple frappant
et quand coronavirus est venu il y a un
jeune de Bambo
il met son numéro là-bas tu viens tu
compenses ton numéro lorsore quand il
coupe l'eau qui a pu faire ça
moi je suis fier d'être Bambeto mais
c'est pas nous c'est pas puisque tout le
monde sont violents ou bien nous leur
parents qui nous excite pour sortir pour
faire la violence non ces enfants sont
pas occupés je vais vous donner un
exemple frappant
ici il y a plus de 10000 maisons détruit
ici
au village ses enfants sont là certains
sont dans les ghettos et aussi étant
n'est pas ni rien d'abord exemples qu'on
école publique ou bien une centaine de
santé ici si tu as 10 enfants 15 enfants
école privée
certains vont aller jusqu'à 4e année 5e
année ils vont abandonner
leurs enfants
donc on n'est pas de violent
on a de moins exemples je n'ai jamais
allé à l'école
mais depuis 2015 j'ai eu mon agrément
communal 2015 je compte pas combien des
enfants qui sont passés au centre un
mois deux mois un an grâce à l'ONG on a
retrouvé leurs parents j'ai des
partenaires aujourd'hui avec Terre des
Hommes exemple si tu es des hommes ils
voient identifie un enfant rapidement
c'est à mon centre là-bas c'est là-bas
ils vont confier les enfants jusqu'à bon
faire recherche leurs parents de ses
enfants s'il quitte à Liberia bah
en tout cas terre des hommes après ils
vont chercher comment retourner l'enfant
là à sa famille donc c'est pas pour
parler tellement et les diplômes merci
on demande le retour de l'État chez nous
inch'Allah nous allons faire mieux que
ça moi j'allais faire mieux que ce que
j'ai en train de faire seulement que moi
je rêve d'avoir mon centre rien section
sociale là vous allez regrouper les
enfants pour apprendre les métiers
certains vont à l'école merci beaucoup
les invités merci mon Président merci